thank you for being here i'm thrilled to
be here
merry christmas and you know what merry
christmas
as you know we are uh
well we're celebrating christmas now
because frankly we're just not sure
mankind is going to make it to december
25th yeah let's do it now
we don't want to miss our last christmas
and then we will know that this is our
last christmas too which will make it
that much more special
so nice of you to dress up in the spirit
uh
doesn't it aren't you feeling
christmassy right now i am i
love christmas and i still i i don't
think it's ever too early to start the
music it is a little too early with the
uh
decorations i think i'd get sick of them
by by christmas eve
but i i just love it i love it love it
love it yeah well
we did this again we're doing it now
because we're not we think things are
just going to come to an end in about
four weeks
oh god oh lord good thing we can
laugh about it conan can we though can i
i don't know maybe we can't we'll find
out
i can laugh at anything now i'm that
medicated uh
you know there's i have a little bit of
a bone to pick with you jane lynch oh
okay sure
and and you're universally beloved
people love you
and i you know i i'm such a huge fan of
your work
but i do i do have a complaint which is
you've been on my show many many many
times
and every time you're on my show you
come out you sit down
and then you immediately start talking
to andy
and you do that because you and andy
have a prior relationship
you worked on a stage show years ago
before i knew andy
you always sit down you start talking to
andy and then you keep talking to andy
this is an actual this is the typical
interview
that i do with you where look at not
even making eye contact
with me not even looking at me only
looking at andy
and i i find it very insulting well i'm
sorry but that
i wouldn't have thought that was true
until i saw that photographic evidence
but i'm sure we included you in the
conversations i'm sure
i don't know i think you're just easily
left out is andy there tonight
uh well yeah andy's sitting in the in
the audience hey andy can you hear me
hi jane hey how you doing i'm doing fine
how's your dog you've had him for her
for a year now right uh
daisy yeah a little over a year oh
little dollop of daisy i love that dog
she's so cute i love that you keep
taking pictures of her and posting it on
twitter it's great
yeah well she's very photogenic she's a
very pretty dog and she
just keeps getting bigger and bigger
it's you know would you say you're a dog
person you know i was getting a pony
when i got a puppy would you say that
you're a dog person now
oh absolutely i always was you know i i
have uh he's talking about being a dog
person go ahead what yeah
uh yeah no i uh i do i've always been a
dog person yeah i'm in everything i love
animals
i would have cats if my kids weren't
allergic
mm-hmm you know yeah do you like i i
usually have cats but uh that
i they both passed away in the last
couple of years but i do have uh two
dogs we usually have three
believe it or not we have two cocker
spaniels now um and one of them is kind
of an [ __ ]
and the other one is just really old and
blind and deaf but we love them both
equally
yeah andy ask conan if he's a um
animal person just so we can include oh
[ __ ] you're right
um hey conan you've got a dog right yes
i have two dogs
tell us about them loki and bosco
they're great dogs
yeah yeah look what kind of dogs are
they conan they're golden retrievers
okay hey your dog is a mix isn't
isn't she isn't daisy a mix isn't she
like a mother so she's not a purebred
like
i hate when people get purebreds that
just uh you know my counters
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm i'm cutting it
off
jane i i think that you and i should
talk when there isn't someone
interrupting us
okay i think that's probably a good idea
whatever i'll get with you after the
show
sounds great it's great to hear your
voice i'm sorry i can't see your face
that's all right